we just thought there was a real need to
kind of bring to the fore the
exceptional quality air of African
coffee the delivery of some of the
really the best coffees in the world and
we wanted people to experience that and
more than just a being from another we
wanted to create a brand around that
often African African didn't have the
best connotations around the world and
in a separate time we wanted to open a
place and our welcome to everyone you
felt like you could just walk in there
was no pretense and really experience
gourmet exceptional quality barista
coffee and so we saw a gap for that in
South Africa
from the elements in store the posters
the cups the descriptors we have on our
coffee bags you know to the small but
really important conversations that the
baristas have with the customers in
store we really wanted to bring that to
motherland
coffee company brand across
we have a drink in the menu which is
also quite popular called The Dictator
and it says make the day obey you so
it's a double espresso got a real kick
to it
Africa's coffee it's time is now